before russia's invasion three months
ago ukraine was known as the world's
breadbasket it exported 12 percent of
the world's wheat 15 of its corn and
half of its sunflower oil but with its
black sea port such as odessa blocked by
russian warships goods can only travel
on congested land routes that are far
less efficient
it's led to food shortages that threaten
to push tens of millions of people into
food insecurity and famine
it is absolutely essential that we allow
these ports to open because this is not
just about ukraine this is about
the poorest of the poor around the world
who are on the brink of starvation as we
speak
so i asked president putin if you have
any heart at all
to please open these ports
secretary general antonio gutierrez is
warning there is no solution to the
growing global food crisis without
reintegrating ukraine's food production
into world markets
russia must permit the safe and secure
export of grains stored in ukrainian
ports
alternative transportation routes can be
explored even if we know that by itself
they will not be enough to solve the
problem at a food security meeting at
the un america's top diplomat urged
countries to make significant new
contributions to humanitarian
organizations facing food insecurity he
also called on countries with
significant grain and fertilizer
reserves to help there are an estimated
22 million tons of grain sitting in
silos in ukraine right now
food that could immediately go toward
helping those in need if it can simply
get out of the country
food suppliers around the world have
already been declining because of
warming temperatures and the pandemic
gutierrez says talks can prevent a
crisis but with the war in ukraine
expected to continue long-term many are
questioning whether that's possible
victoria gatenby al jazeera